i mean like when did you guys learn how
to swim oh so
my mom my mom like swims competitively
and still does
wow okay that's what i got right now so
yeah she still does uh like triathlons
and stuff oh [ __ ]
and she's like one of like fastest women
in her area and she's like
nearly like 55 or something like that
yeah damn she's she's beautiful
she's so much more healthy than me it's
so sad
like when i go back home and she wants
to like go on a bike ride i'm like dying
and she's like just like breathing like
a casual 50k
bike ride let's go that's what she does
she's like 50k bike ride nothing
did she watch the cycling special i was
like i thought i raised you better
she's like pathetic like no no really
the footage if you saw the raw footage
but yeah so my mom taught me like i like
i've always known how to swim
i don't remember not being i i went to
like a swimming school i remember like
swimming was part of my curriculum
in like school oh really yeah yeah yeah
so we had like a local like swimming
pool
next like not next to us but like really
really close to our school i remember
one like monday mornings was just
dedicated
to learning how to swim wow yeah i mean
i'm not a
strong swimmer by any means but i can
still i still know the basics
like to me it's still scary um whenever
i
go out and i swim and i can't feel the
bottom i don't know there's
there's like there's like the the fear
there's something so wholesome about
hearing that
why i don't know just sounds like a
child problem
can't touch the floor i mean in a
swimming pool it's fine but like out
like out on out in the sea i remember
the first time what's worse is when i
can actually feel
like something underneath something yeah
that's when i'm scared
yeah i mean like if i don't know
something like in a pool completely fine
i didn't give a [ __ ] if i can't feel the
bottom
if i'm like i remember the first time
i've realized it when my when
we were on the beach it was it was
brighton beach's work so it wasn't it
wasn't exactly a [ __ ]
thrilling beach and i remember like my
mates just though we we're kind of just
like oh yeah let's go swim out and uh
swim out
you know two words like the [ __ ] boys
are and i've never done it before but i
knew i'd swim
and i remember we got there and i
this is the first time in my life that i
had swam that far out right and this is
the first time in my life where
i i got i got to this point and i
started kicking down
and my whole life experience had taught
me no matter how deep it is you can
still stand up
and so it was it was this it was this
realization where we get there and we
start flowing on the water and i'm just
like
where's the floor where's where's the
where's where's the ocean where was your
six foot yeah
yeah you take floors for granted yeah
exactly right
like i've never had a swimming pool
where like i couldn't like stand up at
least something like my tiptoes yeah
like i sink down a little bit
and then you know i can still see like
the surface of the water i'm still in my
tiptoes i can reach the surface quite
easily
um so this was the first time where i
had i'd gone this far out
and i had the realization of oh okay um
there is
no edges to this pool that i can quickly
grab onto
i've got a swim literally like all the
way back to the [ __ ] beach and
and the beach like you know that scene
in like movies where you know
the character gets vertigo where they
look down and like the ground just
suddenly like zooms out yeah that's
exactly how i look
that's exactly what the beach looked
like when i turned around and it's just
like the beach just went
zoom like that and i was just like oh
[ __ ] that's why you don't really you
know you shouldn't be swimming if you're
getting even like one percent tired like
you should turn back too yeah
i was already pretty tired yeah you
should you should turn the [ __ ] off some
people drown that's probably like the
closest i've come to drowning as well
people get tired and they swim out and
then they they're like they're tired
by the time they turn around yeah
they're [ __ ] it's so sad and
and yeah i i remember like i remember
turning around and being like okay
i've got to [ __ ] do this because i
because one of the like the scariest
life literally my life literally depends
on it and i was like
guys i think i think i've got to turn
back and
uh i don't think i kind of conveyed how
[ __ ] terrified i was to my mates
because they were like yeah we're just
gonna keep going without school with you
and i'm like
okay okay i'm gonna turn back now um so
yeah what a great group of friends yeah
those are bad mates but
if they're letting you like do that dude
i mean i i
i didn't have a good group of mates when
i was growing up if i heard even like a
breath from my friend that sounded a
little too heavy or mushroom i'm like
turn the [ __ ] around
get the [ __ ] back especially when you
get further out the waves get stronger
so
yeah exactly and then the currents come
in and that's when it gets really
[ __ ] scary
i mean i i can't think of anything more
depressing than just [ __ ] dying and
trying
at least if at least if i'm gonna die on
a beach let me die on a good beach
like a nice beer come to wales man we've
got the finest
finest beaches